ja wir erleben gerade im Zeitraffer
ausgelöst durch den ukrainekrieg und die
ausbleibenden Gaslieferungen nach
Deutschland erleben wir im Zeitraffer
etwas was Leute zu denen ich auch
erzähle schon lange bevor Putin in die
Ukraine einmarschiert ist befürchtet
haben nämlich dass diese schöne
Erzählung der Energiewende die wir in
Deutschland schon seit einigen Jahren
inzwischen von fast allen Parteien
ursprünglich mal für den Grünen aber
inzwischen von fast allen Parteien mit
erzählt dass diese Erzählung grandios
scheitert und sie sich eigentlich als
ein Märchen entpuppt eine schöne
märchenerzählung die einfach an der
Wirklichkeit zerbricht und zwar erleben
wir diesen Winter das nicht nur das Gas
knapp zu werden droht so wie es aussieht
kommen wir je nach Temperaturen durch
diesen Winter doch noch einigermaßen
durch was die Heizung betrifft der
nächste Winter steht aber vor der Tür
und gleichzeitig erleben wir gerade dass
es mit der Stromversorgung wirklich eng
wird und wir vielleicht im Januar oder
Februar durchaus mit Stromausfällen
rechnen müssen die dann zwar angekündigt
werden also keine Blackouts im
eigentlichen Sinne aber die glaube ich
viele Bürger zum Aufwecken aus diesem
Märchen bringen und ich erinnere da an
das Kaisers neue Kleider man sagt denn
letztendlich der Kaiser ist hier nackt
so stehen wir jetzt also da quasi nackt
nicht vorbereitet wie sollen wir durch
diesen Winter kommen was glauben Sie was
kann im schlimmsten Fall sie haben
gesagt Stromausfälle befürchten sie
schon im Januar Februar was kann im
schlimmsten Fall passieren dass Sie uns
einmal Eintauchen in dieses Szenario ähm
ja es wird jetzt immer vom vom Blackout
geredet und dann sagen die die
Netzbetreiber und und auch die in der
Regierung Verantwortlichen sofort nein
nein das Blackout Risiko ist gering das
vermeide ich nichts beurteilen ein
bundesweite
Sprachgebrauch ist sozusagen die Lichter
ausgehen weil der stromfeld nennen will
fehlt nennen wir das Blackout so ist es
im Alltagssprachgebrauch
gemeint die Fachleute netzingenieure die
Reden von Blackout nur wenn es ein
unkontrollierter gesamtzusammenbruch des
gesamten Stromnetzes ist der dann
durchaus auch Tage andauern kann weil
das befürchten sie aber nicht das kann
jederzeit und zwar immer passieren die
Gefahr ist immer da aber sie hängt jetzt
nicht an der Strom mangelage unbedingt
so das die Gefahr ist aber auch da auf
die muss man sie auch vorbereiten was
aber durchaus ich für wahrscheinlich
halte und was auch sich besonders in
Baden-Württemberg schon erste
Ankündigung in die Richtung gab ist das
die Stromnetzbetreiber um einen Blackout
zu verhindern sich nicht mehr anders zu
helfen zu wissen als den sogenannten
braunen out das sind kontrollierte
Stromausfälle zeitlich begrenzt für 90
Minuten vielleicht in einzelne
Stadtteilen Gebieten je nachdem machen
wo einfach mal der Strom abgestellt wird
weil einfach in dem Moment nicht genug
Strom da ist und das ist wenn man
vorgewandt wird zu verkraften und der
Tiefkühltruhe bleibt vielleicht für 19
Minuten auch noch eingelassen
aber was bedeutet für die Wirtschaft die
Frage stellt sich und ich glaube
politisch wird es auch verheerend weil
es wird dann einige Leute geben die dann
sagen liebe Bundesregierung was treibt
die da eigentlich wie kann das sein
direkt weiter Liebe Bundesregierung was
treibt wieder eigentlich wir haben sie
ja hier sitzen eine Herz von der FDP mit
in der Regierung ich bemerke dass wir in
jeder Sitzungswoche uns mit dem Thema
Energie befassen und in der dynamischen
Lage da auch immer wieder neue
Entscheidungen treffen damit genau das
was sie befürchten nicht eintreten wird
wichtig ist glaube ich dass wir schnell
reagieren gute
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen treffen beim Gas
haben wir jetzt mit den lng-terminist
wirklich Gas gegeben im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes
1 % jetzt bei dieser Kälte ne es ist
besonders kalt ist es besonders hart
also die Speicher sind ja weiterhin noch
noch ganz gut gefüllt jetzt kommen die
lng-termin ist nach und nach ans Netz
das erste jetzt am Samstag und dann bin
ich zuversichtlich dass wir die
Speicher beim Gas im nächsten Jahr auch
voll bekommen mit mit LNG Gas und ja
beim bei der Stromversorgung treffen wir
jede Woche Entscheidungen wie wir jedes
Kilowatt das zur Verfügung steht bis zu
nutzen können und ich glaube das ist
auch richtig so wir sind eine dynamische
Lage man muss also bei Ihnen bei der FDP
der meldet sich jetzt kein Unternehmen
durch die BASF zum Beispiel die Alarm
schlägt und sagt also wenn es so
weitergeht wissen wir nicht mehr wie wir
produzieren sollen doch
selbstverständlich melden Sie sich bei
uns und fragen nach aber ich glaube es
ist gut wenn wir dann nicht mit Panik
reagieren und kopflos sagen ja es wird
alles furchtbar sondern wenn wir das als
Auftrag für uns nehmen uns sehr an
Schreibtisch zu setzen und Lösungen zu
finden gerade Strom zur Mangelware wir
sind Industrienation ich glaube jetzt
mit Schreibtisch und Lösungen ich glaube
wir haben diesen Punkt ein bisschen
überschritten kann das sein
ich glaube wie gesagt Name auch schon
viele Entscheidungen getroffen die uns
da weiterhelfen werden
aber wir haben die Entscheidung
getroffen dass die AKWs über den über
den Dezember hinaus bleiben das ist wenn
ich da kurz einhaken darf das finde ich
also es ist ja ihrer Partei und Fraktion
hoch anzurechnen dass sie es geschafft
haben das durchzusetzen dass wenigstens
die drei die jetzt noch laufen
Atomkraftwerke zumindest mal bis April
laufen die große Frage ist nur was kommt
danach ich spreche auch mit auf FDP
Abgeordneten die in dem Thema drin sind
und habe dass die auch direkt gefragt
und im Hintergrund ich habe dann immer
gefragt ja gebt ihr euch damit jetzt
zufrieden oder wartet erstmal ab und
dann haben die immer gesagt ja mal
abwarten wie der Winter ist danach ist
eine andere Lage sprich wir machen eine
Energiepolitik wo Entscheidungen
getroffen werden die Jahrzehnte Bestand
haben und die für Jahrzehnte im Voraus
auch getroffen werden müssen betreiben
wir jetzt von Winter zu Winter mit der
Winter kalt was jetzt kommt der
Stromverbrauch in Frankreich wieder
durch vor allem steigen und ich bin
Strom Heiz lassen und das wird auch bei
uns zu Problemen führen dann gibt es
vielleicht dann spätestens im April
wieder eine neue ermüdende
atomkraftdiskussion wo man dann wieder
auf grüne Befindlichkeit Rücksicht
nehmen muss dann vielleicht einen
streckenbetrieb einen
streckstreckstreckbetrieb bis zum
nächsten Winter beschließt aber das ist
doch kein Konzept man muss doch diese
ganze Energiewende mal grundsätzlich auf
den Prüfstand stellen und pragmatisch
entscheiden wo machen erneuerbare sind
wo brauchen wir vielleicht doch noch
mehr und länger unsere Atomkraftwerke
die zu den sichersten der Welt gehören
wo können wir Gas im eigenen Land
fordern fördern das muss doch einen
Gesamtstrategie sein und nicht von
Landtagswahl zu Landtagswahl und von
Winter zu Winter mit der
Energiesicherheit unseres Landes zu
spielen das ist doch also ich merke ich
bin der fassungslos und gerade ihre
Partei wurde dafür gewählt dass sie
diesen Unsinn aufhält oder zumindest
verhindert und das viele FDP Wähler ist
für diese Frage glaube ich wird
entscheidend sein ob sie zunächst mal
noch mehr Kreuz bei Ihnen machen das
sollten sich bewusst sein
wenn sie reagieren oder das einfach mal
so hinnehmen ich also sie wissen ja dass
ist nicht an uns gescheitert ist noch
eine noch eine längere Laufzeit für die
Atomkraftwerke zu erreichen und jetzt
sind wir gespannt dass der Wirtschafts-
und Energieminister dieses Strategie
vorliegt die Sie diese verlangen und der
ist da im Lied und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir dann eine gute
Lösung finden also ich glaube nicht
daran dass die Atomkraftwerke wieder
aufgenommen werden also habe ich habe
jetzt verstanden das ist jetzt dann auch
das Ende und ich würde dann positiv
sagen wie Atomkraft ist tot es liebe die
Kernkraft es müssen glaube ich neue
Lösungen in Richtung Kernkraft weil sie
gefragt hatten das ist eigentlich mein
Stand äh her es wird glaube ich nie mit
den allein mit den erneuerbaren Energien
gehen das ist ja dieses Märchen den wir
jetzt seit 30 Jahren hinterherlaufen
aber das gibt ihm dieses Szenario in der
Nacht bei Flaute und so weiter da gibt
es herum und deshalb bin ich aber
positiv und zuversichtlich dass die
Vernunft in der Regierung siegen wird
die neue Kernkraft es gibt ja jetzt
Ansätze das habe ich gelesen in China
war auch in Deutschland gibt es
überall wahrscheinlich noch ja aber das
geht auch relativ schnell also über die
Medien liest also ich weiß bin jetzt
keine Kernkraft für Forschung aber ich
denke mal das was ja vor allen Dingen
versäumt wurde in den letzten 30 Jahren
ist ja eine Kernkraft zu forschen es
gibt aber die Forschung und ähm ich
denke mal dass wir in langfristig
perspektivisch die Kernkraft wieder in
Angriff nehmen werden ist ja auch das
CO2 einsparendste Energie allerdings
System allerdings bis dahin müssen wir
uns noch irgendwie so lang humpeln
jetzt komplett aus und dann haben die
Grünen werden niemals das ist eine
Illusion also dass die jetzt die alten
schloren die ja immer noch die ähm dass
sie die wieder anschauen also gut dann
habe gestern
da hat es auch geschafft den Krieg zu
nutzen um Ihnen den Pazifismus
auszutreiben warum sollte ich sagen es
ist so man sollte sich glaube ich von
dieser alten Atomkraft sowieso lösen und
versuchen da auch die an die Technik
zusammen und eher neuen Lösungen und
dann von mir auszusagen wenn die Leute
die neue Kernkraft überhaupt ins Visier
zu nehmen langfristiger das ist
langfristige Entwicklungen ich glaube
für den Winter
wir haben ja die Atomkraftwerke auch
noch alle drei ja noch im schnell was
mich interessieren würde wir sprechen
gleich darüber dass unsere Demokratie
gesichert ist das ist gleich ihr großes
Thema ich möchte aber einmal über die
Dienste sprechen viele befürchten sollte
es zu stromausfallen können sollte es zu
einem Blackout kommen dann könnte es
sogar soweit kommen dass es plunderung
gibt das sind sozialen Unfrieden gibt
bleiben sie darauf sind wir vorbereitet
hier ein also
meine These ist immer die die beste
Sicherheitspolitik ist eine gute
Sozialpolitik und wenn sie schwierige
soziale Verhältnisse haben sie auch
zwangsläufig mehr Kriminalität insofern
ist das Szenario dass sie jetzt gerade
beschreiben ein durchaus realistisches
Szenario aber ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden die deutsche Polizei
die deutschen Nachrichtendienste jetzt
schon in den Startlöchern stehen und
sich darauf vorbereiten denn dort findet
Vorbereitung statt das kann ich
versichern und insofern glaube ich nicht
dass das eine ernsthafte Gefährdung
unseres Systems sein wird wenn wir so
ein Blackout haben werden also das
staatlichen